une messe dominicale qui tourne au drame
en egypte un incendie s'est déclaré dans
ce bâtiment abritant une église copte
orthodoxe aux alentours de 9h ce matin
5000 fidèles s'y étaient rassemblés pour
prier
la tragédie s'est produite dans le
quartier très dense et populeux demba ba
dans la ville de guise et c'est la
deuxième plus grande ville d'égypte
après le caire sur la rive opposée du
nil des témoins racontent que les
flammes ont bloqué l'entrée de l'église
la seule porte de sortie est dans la
détresse provoqué une bousculade
certaines personnes se sont jetées par
les fenêtres pour échapper au feu
raconte ce témoin l'un 117 aussi étendu
une garderie effet beaucoup de jeunes
victimes
j'avais des enfants et des aînés nous
avons sauvé tout ce que nous pouvions
raconte se blesser en tout cas ce
qu'annonce pompiers des dizaines
d'ambulances ont été dépêchées sur les
lieux mais les rues étroites et
sinueuses ont compliqué les opérations
l'origine de l'incendié reste à
éclaircir le ministère de l'intérieur
privilégient la piste d'un faux contact
électrique dans un climatiseur vétustes
du bâtiment d'autres évoquent la
surcharge d'une génératrice le parquet
égyptien a ouvert une enquête sur
twitter le président égyptien abdel
fattah al-sisi a présenté ses
condoléances aux familles des victimes
innocentes qui sont partis rejoindre
leur seigneur dans l'un de ces lieux de
culte écrit-il il faut dire que les
incendies meurtriers ne sont pas rares
dans la mégalopole tentaculaire du caire
des millions d'égyptiens vivent dans des
quartiers informels doter des
infrastructures mal entretenues ici le
fil et radio radio canada montréal